public housing is often considered low
in quality and high in crime but it's a
totally different story in Singapore
government built apartments in Singapore
are clean safe and well maintained and
about 80% of Singaporean households live
in them Singapore is also one of the few
countries in the world to achieve almost
full homeownership status over 90
percent of the city's households own
their own homes but it wasn't always
this way
here's how Singapore fixed its housing
problem in 1959 when Singapore obtained
self-governance from the British the
city was having a severe housing crisis
struggling to accommodate its growing
population in 1960 Singapore's first
Prime Minister Lee Kuan Yew and his
government set up the Housing and
Development Board or HDV a public
housing agency with a mission to build
rental units for the poor at the time
many immigrants including those from
Malaysia were living in unhygenic slums
amid increasing racial tension between
Chinese and Malays the HDB had a hard
time convincing them to leave their
informal settlements for new high-rises
then came the still unexplained fire
which broke out in the squatter
settlement of bukit host:we on the 25th
of May 1961 an area of 400,000 square
meters was razed four people were killed
and around 16 thousand left homeless the
government successfully rehoused all of
the fire victims within a year and built
new housing on the site of the disaster
in the next five years it's speedy
reaction won over the people and paved
the way for future public housing
projects Singapore must be one of the
few places in the world where a
statutory Board satisfactorily completed
everything it set out to do in its first
five-year plan
by 1965 the HDP managed to build over
51,000 apartments rehousing 400,000
people a quarter of their then
population solving the housing shortage
apart from renting out apartments HCB
also started to sell them in 1964
Singaporeans are required to save part
of their salaries in a state managed
plan called Central Provident Fund but
first the fund only provided for
retirement then in 1968 the government
allowed the use of the fund for housing
expenses helping more people become
homeowners unlike many other countries
Singapore's public housing is not only
for the poor instead it caters to the
masses citizens within certain income
ceilings can buy various types of
property from basic to room apartments
to upmarket units and condominiums with
a swimming pool and a gym their prices
are usually twenty to thirty percent
cheaper than those in the private market
but you've got to apply an order the
apartment first
then wait several years for it to be
built also you can't sell it until you
finish the five-year minimum occupation
period today HDPE has planned designed
and built over 1 million apartments
spreading over the city state the
percentage of people living in public
housing has grown from 9 percent in 1960
to 82 percent in 2016 and the
homeownership rate has also increased
rapidly with the rise of Singapore's
economy Singapore's public housing is
considered as one of the world's best
but some see it as a way of social
control for instance quotas ensure a mix
of Chinese Indians and Malays in each
HDB bloc aiming to carefully integrate
ethnic groups and prevent the formation
of a volatile racial Enclave but still a
mighty agency with effective policies
and strong political will has fixed
Singapore's housing crisis and improved
the living conditions of millions
you